i just wanted to ask what your position
is on amnesty for you know law-abiding
citizens that have been here 20-plus
years or something like that so my
position on amnesty is the same as my
position on immigration which is that if
we have the resources to analyze several
hundred million irs returns every year
then we have the resources to analyze on
an individual level whether people
should stay or whether they should go
there are a lot of undocumented
immigrants who've been living here for a
really long time illegal immigrants and
and they didn't immigrate illegally but
that doesn't mean the end of the world a
lot of people overstay their visas a lot
of people came through the southern
border have been very productive
citizens and would be excellent
additions to the country as citizens and
there are a lot of people who have not
it's up to the country to decide whether
they should stay or whether they should
go i don't think that presence in the
country alone is enough to demarcate
whether somebody should stay or go and i
don't think duration of presence in the
country is enough to demarcate whether
somebody should stay or or they should
go right we shouldn't be doing this as
like entire group of people from this
age to this age who came in in this year
from this country should get to stay i
don't understand why it would work that
way again i believe in seeing people as
individuals this is true of illegal
immigrants as well people who came here
illegally if you are a benefit to the
country is it a good idea for us to
abort them i don't think so